derniers mois alors aujourd'hui je vous
emmène pour une séance d'entraînement
avec moi c'est parti claire d'ouvéa
toujours le sourire quand on lui parle
d'aviron la sportive de 23 ans
aujourd'hui en équipe de france a
commencé cette passion en cinquième avec
sa meilleure amie dans le club de meulan
les mureaux hardricourt pourtant ce
sport n'était pas sa discipline de
prédilection elle préféré à l'époque le
tri nations
j'avoue que j'ai tout fait pour échoué
aux examens d'entrée pour la section
sportive mais finalement j'ai été prise
quand même et puis au début c'était pas
c'était juste pour être avec les copains
les copines et puis finalement ça a
commencé à bien plaire et puis j'ai
commencé à bien avancer aussi et ça aide
pas mal les bons résultats clairs bové
aujourd'hui l'essentiel associations
sportives mantaise les collectionne
depuis ses débuts la rameuse a notamment
remporté la médaille d'argent aux
championnats d'europe en deux de couple
poids légers en 2019 la sportive a
également été vice championne du monde
en moins de 23 ans est championne de
france à plusieurs reprises ça fait
quand même un petit moment maintenant
que que je m'entraîne dur et donc ça
fait du bien que les efforts et paye
mais je me souviens encore d'être assise
en minimes sur les pontons des
championnats de france avec ma meilleure
amie en disant un jour ben on sera dans
cette finale et on a réussi à faire
cette finale et à être championne de
france ensemble donc ça c'est cool mais
c'est vrai qu'au début on s'est dit que
ce serait un beau rêve
et finalement le beau rêve se réaliser
quoi un autre rêve pourrait se réaliser
cet été clair bové fait partie des
cadres de cette équipe de france
d'aviron qui s'envoleront pour tokyo la
rameuse a de grandes ambitions sur ce
rendez-vous un podium olympique
ce serait franchement c'est un beau rêve
on a les armes pour se battre dans la
catégorie et pour faire des belles
choses donc c'est un beau rêve mais
un petit peu réaliste quand même pour
préparer au mieux la compétition la
sportive à s'entraîner jusqu'au 15
juillet dans le jura à tokyo ses courses
se dérouleront du 26 au 30 juillet dans
la catégorie deux de couple femmes poids
léger